we the jury in the above entitled matter
has to count one
unintentional second degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
derek chovin has been found guilty on
all three counts for the death of george
floyd
and social media is now flooded with
reactions from celebrities
with some stars simply writing justice
lock him up
and hallelujah guilty guilty
guilty on all three counts gail
now for the first time after sitting
through the trial and being out
that he is now heading to jail tonight
nearly a year after floyd's death
the former minneapolis police officer
now awaits sentencing
the three other officers involved have
been charged with aiding and abetting
and they're expected to be tried jointly
in august
but i have to tell you when the verdict
was read i mean we started hearing
horns honking i think you felt jaws
dropping
i think people thought maybe you'd get
one but to get
all three i think is a very stunning
thing following the verdict oprah shared
a photo of george floyd and wrote
relieved and emotional in ways i didn't
expect
i cried tears of joy as each verdict was
read
chloe bailey wrote on twitter i'm
shaking thank you god
sky jackson wrote lock him up and throw
away the key
and many stars are reflecting on the
death at the center of this story
and acknowledging there's more
injustices to keep fighting for
matt james tweeted the marathon
continues
shonda rhimes said this verdict does not
bring back mr floyd
but justice is truth justin timberlake
wrote
this verdict is just the first step in a
long line of injustice against the black
community
often with no consequences the work is
not nearly done
no one should be above the law and
today's verdict sends that message
but it's not enough we can't stop here
in order to deliver real change and
reform
we can and we must do more to reduce the
likelihood that tragedy like this will
ever happen and occur again
and this takes acknowledging and
confronting head-on
systemic racism and the racial
disparities that exist in policing
and in our criminal justice system more
broadly
floyd's death last year inspired many
celebrities to add their voices to the
black lives matter movement
and take part in demonstrations around
the world to speak out against police
brutality
as cbs news's gail king commented
following the verdict
the images of floyd's final moments
perhaps
said it all but what you could not deny
is that videotape
showed how george floyd was literally
gasping for his life with his knuckles
trying to touch
the tire of the police car to try to do
anything to get
that last gasp of air that unfortunately
as we know never came